I didn't know what to do so Satan talked
me out of hot water in my first thought
was to get away but the FDR was close
sigh headed west took the Holland Tunnel
but there were cracks in it and I
thought to myself this can't be right i
mean the hudson river was dribbling its
way into the holland tunnel it and when
I got out of Port off into a parking lot
to contemplate exactly what I just seen
I can see across the ribbon to the city
and they were cause you're sliding off
the west side highway just disappearing
into the Hudson and say thing was in the
passing is he telling me cute driving
head south forget about it get out while
I could and I was saying something back
to him when the new york city cop taps
on my window were you in there talking
to a buddy boy and I'm thinking to
myself whats in new york city cop doing
in New Jersey but I said it's a officer
he floated off my wallpaper made me
steal this van which crippled boy at
that point also draws the sky so I
ripped out of their start it back into
the city thinking they never follow me
but they did the entire NYPD left into
their cars and follow me into the
leaking tunnel except by this time the
cracks were bigger and the water was
rushing in I hydroplane the whole way
through with hundreds of cops on my tail
blaring their sirens I felt like a folk
no kids sections of the tunnel were
caving in behind me water was filling
the entire place the minute I flew about
the river kicked in the Hudson came
crashing down flooding the holland
tunnel and the NYPD as if the waters
parted Red Sea falling in on the
Egyptian army and I I was Moses safe
from the other side with my people true
story